and so obviously there's not a kind of
one-size-fits-all which i think
previously people had
had kind of fallen uh victim to uh
when that shift occurs which really is
kind of already underway
um what is the impact on the market side
right so where do you see that capital
going if that 60 goes to 75 90 you know
even 100
where does the capital go and then kind
of how do you see that uh changing the
market dynamics as well
yeah so a couple things there you know
first if we look at sort of the aum of
hedge funds vc firms and pe firms over
that time period
they've clearly been the biggest
beneficiaries so back in 1976 there was
less than a billion dollars allocated to
hedge funds in total
in 96 that was 130 billion today that's
a trillion dollars
right so those are really public market
and some public credit
uh investment opportunities for the most
part in 1976 there was less than four
billion dollars in venture capital
uh funding in 96 it was 39 billion today
that's approaching 500 billion right so
that starts to matriculate itself in the
private markets
and then you know probably most
impressively for pe firms there's less
than a billion dollars and 76 and 96
there's 160 billion and today that's one
and a half trillion
and they had two tailwinds right lower
interest rates
make lbos a lot more attractive but they
also have the you know genesis of the
high-yield law market by
you know milken and all the folks over
at drexel so you kind of have the birth
of an asset class concurrent with this
massive capital allocation shift so
you're seeing people go into private
equity you're seeing people going to
venture and you're seeing people call
the public markets
and what becomes interesting is at the
same time that you have these assets
flowing
into the public markets the number of
public companies have been cut in half
right so from 1996 to today you have
half the number of publicly traded
companies that you do
we're just at three quarters of where we
were in 1974 so you have
greater assets chasing less and less
opportunities
uh there was a really good academic
paper published called the
u.s listing gap by folks out of i
believe cornell and ohio state
and they showed that back in 76 the the
market cap of u.s stocks was 3.3
trillion
which was you know 49 of gdp and today
it's 38 trillion which is
176 gdp right the average market cap of
a company was 650 million bucks back
then and today's 10 billion dollars
so yeah when you think about that it
naturally leads the price appreciation
because there's only so many places you
can allocate that capital
got it and so obviously um not only are
we seeing
um kind of this movement of capital but
this is all happening simultaneous to
a pandemic on economic recession kind of
all of the macro shifts that we've seen
how does um the uh kind of catalyst for
all of this
and then the reaction of lower interest
rates and a bunch of quantitative easing
how did that kind of perfect storm of um
events
change or accelerate kind of this shift
sure absolutely so you know what i've
said historically is
qe infinity kind of pushed people out
the risk curve right so it changed your
savings account into your checking
account the bond market into the savings
account the equity market the bond
market the venture markets the equity
market
and it gave rise to the crypto market as
the new venture market
right and you're kind of seeing that
happen so you know in in the 30 years
before the global financial crisis the
fed's balance sheet expanded by 700
billion dollars
that took 10 days in march right you
know we've injected seven trillion
dollars of liquidity into the system
year-to-date
uh with another trillion to two on the
way which is crazy when your bid ask is
now a trillion dollars
but it's not just the fed right so
cumulative central bank balance sheets
have exploded
so from 2000 to 2008 the balance sheets
of the fed the boj
the swiss national bank the boe and the
ecb went from two to four trillion
dollars
then post crisis it went from four to
ten this year alone we've gone from 16
to 22.
so basically eight months we saw as much
cumulative central bank balance sheet
extension as we did seven years
post not only the global financial
crisis but the euro crisis as well
and three times as much during the
decade prior to the posted.com crash
right
so you've seen this insane amount of
liquidity uh that's entered to the
market and i think
you know in march it was really a
seminal moment where we crossed the
rubicon where no one asked how do we pay
for this anymore
right you know the fact that the
democrats and the republicans right now
are arguing over one at two trillion
dollars
it is asinine if you think about where
we were
you know ten years ago and i think
that's really the big
difference today versus you know our our
father's qe generation
right where a lot of people said oh
inflation's going to come
inflation's going to come but it never
really materialized i think you had a
completely different macro backdrop
uh then versus now right so prior to
global financial crisis banks had zero
excess reserves they were right against
their limits
you know so when the fed started to
expand its balance sheet uh that went
into the excess reserves the banks had
to held it never really materialized in
m1 and m2
uh this year you know you have money
going directly into checking accounts
with the stimulus check it looks like
we're going to have another one on the
way before the election
you have federal unemployment benefits
topping people up at greater than the
median salary in this country
you have money going directly to
companies with ppp and eidl
you have the fed literally backstopping
corporate bond purchases
so you're actually seeing a significant
increase in m2 so
uh you know the fed publishes all this
data if you look at fraud charts you can
look at a chart of m2 throughout the
totality of global financial crisis
it's grown in a linear fashion up until
this year um
where it's up you know three trillion
dollars here a day you know to put that
in perspective
it took seven years uh to expand by
three trillion dollars that just
happened in four months
you know so in june which is the last
metric we have m2 is up 25
year over year that's the highest
reading all time the last time it
increased anywhere remotely close to the
space was during world war ii
so you think about the inflationary
pressures that we have
right now where does money go i know
you've spoken about this letter a lot on
this podcast paul tudor jones talks
about
you know backing the fastest horse in
this race and he highlighted
you know nasdaq 100 stocks bitcoin and
gold
and you know he he pointed to bitcoin
there but i think you're seeing that
materialized not only
uh in the credit markets which have
gotten incredibly tight you know
therefore in the equity markets which
rally now back to all-time highs and of
course in this long tale of
you know alternative assets whether it
be you know gold whether it be bitcoin
or whether it be private markets